de 35 37 anos e é mais jovem
adora do tv silvio iria integrar a
equipa como embaixadora projovens faz
acontecer é o seu lema e vai pensar
sobre o papel dos jovens enquanto
participantes ativos
bush por ter pensamentos limitados muito
animadores
se há coisa que o menino os meus cursos
de 60 anos é que nada acontece só falar
e só fazermos caixa do que está mal e do
que nós não concordamos seja seja no meu
caso na minha escola ou seja na minha
cidade e ele disse que eu venho aqui
falar hoje é e eu posso fugir e é o que
vou fazer vou falar da minha experiência
enquanto voluntária dentro da minha
cidade e enquanto participante e
conseguinte da minha associação de
estudantes da escola secundária
francisco rodrigues lobo
há muita coisa que está por fazer e eu
falo por experiência própria e ver que o
icv que sair que não é muito
onde você sabe mais que eu e podem
concordar ou não comigo mas há muita
gente feliz que tudo está mal mas não
podem ficar sentados no sofá à espera
que façam o trabalho por nós porque se
há coisa que eu penso e que eu acho e
acredito que não só os outros vão
arranjar tudo o que está mal e tudo é
que nós achamos que está errado e é isso
que vai num falar em história e tentar
inverter pensamentos que todo o conceito
de teleconsultoria é eu entrei no
projeto já são maioria um projecto de
voluntariado da nossa cidade em que nós
temos que ler várias instituições da
cidade
no meu caso escolhi o espaço jovem
leiria um espaço que eu costumo
frequentar praticamente todos os dias
isso muito bem querida lá e o que eu
tentei fazer os poços jovem um sítio é
não só do convívio onde nós conhecemos
muitas pessoas mas também um espaço nós
podemos citar como podem ver no
powerpoint temos vários
posso estudo lazer e principalmente
criar amizades criar inimizades não só
com pessoas da nossa idade
mexi com ela na casa por exemplo que
está responsável por todos nós quase uma
segunda mãe é assim que o vai e assim
que ela é por nós e é assim que nos
trata e e no verão eu fiz um treino e
muita gente não acreditava no potencial
do espaço jovem achava que não havia
muito a fazer
e foi precisamente por isso que eu fui
lá para inverter o pensamento das
pessoas para mostrar às pessoas que há
muito mais para além do que se vê a olho
nu e acontece muito mais coisas eo
aprendi esta profissional dentro de um
espaço pra mim é um espaço de convívio é
aprendi como é que se trabalha consegue
perceber todos os problemas que
acontecem dentro dessa instituição e
todos os usem previstos que pra eles
passa e que nós não fazemos é mais
pequena ideia e foi muito por isso que
eu entrar e e e tentarem alguma coisa
que eu achasse que estivesse errado ou
que estivessem falta num neste caso o
espaço jovem e acho que é muito isso que
nós precisamos de fazer
acho que não é como eu já tinha efe
não é dizer que tá mal e ficar sentados
podem concordar comigo não é que isso é
muito cuidado nos poços jovem não
acontece tudo convívio mas sim é
apresentações de existem várias
disposições existentes
recebemos muitas vezes vereadores da
câmara mesmo presidente da câmera para
vários projectos que o espaço jovem
envolve e acolhe e aos são coisas muito
importantes em que eu estou muito
orgulhosa de ver na minha cidade voz que
estamos a evoluir não estamos parados
não não somos uma cidade completamente
parada e acho que será muito importante
o mês com desempenho
de presença ativa na minha cidade é ter
entrado procissão distante da minha
escola é muita gente e agora falo pela
parte dos alunos caixes tanto na
organização da escola como propriamente
da associação distante é muito melhor
que muitas associações de estudantes
limitou-se a fazer ofertas ou coisas do
gênero e é minha vista os meus colegas
agora minha família e vamos tentar
inverter todos esses pensamentos e todas
essas atitudes que é pra isso que nós
formamos pista e fizemos isto para os
nossos colegas da escola
fui tentar ter uma seleção de estudantes
completamente diferente completamente
dinâmica e trazer aos nossos amigos
instantes e colegas de escola e perceber
que eu tenho um sítio onde ir quando têm
dúvidas têm os estiverem sozinhos na
escola a sessão distância é só mais um
no um homem que os têm e nós tentamos
englobar toda a gente num sítio só que
neste caso a associação distantes nós
fizemos uma grande campanha e é meu ver
foi uma campanha muito inclusiva e crio
um um esforço imenso
só gente todos os nossos colaboradores e
participantes e 2007 e não foi só a
opção porque muita gente pensa que as
listas jeito só só divertir e não como
podem ver tivemos já distribuídos é
volcheff e cupões de desconto aos nossos
colegas porque a nossa posição distante
não é só virada para a escola
muitas vezes é nós tentamos incluir toda
a gente incluir várias alas está a
cidade representa a cidade próxima
sessão de estudantes porque acho que uma
coisa não se fechem outra nunca pode
perder só nós precisamos sempre da ajuda
de toda a gente à nossa sucessão de
estudantes têm tem vários têm várias
premissas e muitas delas passam é por
marcar a diferença que inclusive era o
nosso slogan
é isso que nós tentávamos mostrar e foi
mesmo isso é nossa intenção e acho que
ficou plenamente que é o nosso evento
internet em que nós tentamos trazer
novas idéias a partir de um ponto de
partida e criar novas novas idéias criar
novas atitude e é mesmo por isso que
chegamos nós não podemos
não podemos mesmo ficar quietinho eu
acho que esse é o maior problema do
nosso país
é acho que há muita gente a trabalhar
claro que sim mas também há muita gente
que ficar em jejum e não faço pra isso e
acho que ser a melhor coisa que nós
temos de inverter no nosso país e
começar por si como a nossa cidade da
nossa escola é a nossa casa por exemplo
há sempre qualquer coisa mas há sempre
qualquer coisa a melhorar
acho que temos que fazer acontecer e não
podemos esperar que o façam por nós é e
que que escute as coisas aconteçam
sozinhas e com isto os 10 e vigilância
pergunta é estão preparados para e verde
muito obrigada